it appears even the king of monsters may
have trouble with his loyal subjects
after reporting last week that the
Godzilla sequel had been pushed back it
now appears that it's lost its director
as well I'm Simon and this is your kaiju
news update deadline reported last week
the Gareth Edwards has left the
legendary produced film in a decision
described as amicable Edwards directed
the 2014 original Godzilla his current
project is Star Wars spin-off rogue one
which comes to theaters this December
the deadline report goes on to shed some
more light on Edwards decision to split
Edwards has his own gestating projects
he wanted to pursue and they are smaller
in scale than the back-to-back tempol
size pictures he is directing with the
Godzilla launch and then the Star Wars
spin-off Godzilla tues release date was
pushed back from June 2018 to march 2019
deadline reports that Edwards and
legendary reached an agreement about
parting ways before this announcement
the search is now underway for a
replacement Godzilla two will be
followed up in 2020 with monster mashup
Godzilla vs. Kong the first Godzilla
premiered in May 2014 and according to
box office mojo it went on to make more
than 500 million dollars worldwide I
would have loved to have seen Edwards
reimagining of other classic kaiju such
as King adoro or Mothra for a Godzilla
sequel but who do you think is best
suited to take over the role let me know
in the comments or come find me on
Twitter i'm at the Jagan or thanks for
watching and for your entertainment news
keep it gamespot